let's talk about the seven ways that you
can boost your
testosterone these are natural things
you can do
the first thing is to make sure you do
not
lower your cholesterol you want to
increase your cholesterol do not go on a
low
fat diet why because cholesterol is the
precursor the building blocks that help
make testosterone and that's one of the
problems too when
your doc puts you on statins statins
block cholesterol which then
end up lowering testosterone and that is
one big challenge so
i'm not telling you not to take your
statin all i'm saying is that you might
want to research it
get with your doctor and find out the
real reason why your cholesterol
might be high and i have some videos on
that
instead of just treating the symptom
let's find out what the actual
cause is but you don't want to go low on
the cholesterol
if you want high testosterone
let's talk about protein moderate
protein
a myth is that you need a lot of protein
to stimulate your testosterone no you
need a moderate amount
now what's a moderate amount well i'd
say about between six to eight ounces
per meal now i'm talking about the
weight of the actual food like a piece
of steak or a hamburger or something
like that i'm not talking about the
grams within that because the grams
within that is a lot less
i do have quite a few videos on protein
i'll put some down below if you want
more information on that but
you just want to avoid too much protein
if you consume too much protein you're
going to get tired and the reason why
you're going to get tired is that your
like half of it can easily be turned
into glucose
so when you turn it into glucose because
your body
doesn't necessarily use amino acids
as its fuel some but not much it has to
be converted into glucose to be used as
fuel so that excess amount of insulin
that's triggered by the glucose
is going to block your testosterone so
just do a moderate amount of protein
number three you want to go low carbs
for the same reason because carbs
increase
insulin so if we keep our insulin low we
can enhance
testosterone and other beneficial
hormones like
growth hormone number four exercise
will stimulate testosterone if
it's high intensity and oval training or
exercise involving the whole body
to the point where you're sweating but
not over training
but the problem is if you're not
sleeping
you don't want to do that okay because
it's going to strain your heart
you want to do long walks for a while
to lower the cortisol so you can sleep
so you can eventually add more exercise
to then increase more testosterone now
just as a side note and i didn't put
this on this chart
is that i always recommend when you do
low carb
it's called keto you also do
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting
improves growth hormone and wherever
growth hormone goes
testosterone goes it tends to follow
similar pathways
and so intermittent fasting is vital to
keep your testosterone levels
normal because if you're doing snacks
and frequent meals
you're just going to increase insulin
and suppress testosterone
that is why a pre-diabetic or someone
with insulin resistance or a diabetic
normally always has low testosterone and
that's going to affect your muscle mass
and it's going to affect your libido and
your energy number five
sleep very very important why because we
want to keep our cortisol
lower increase cortisol the stress
hormone we lower
testosterone we also want to keep
estrogen on the low side
so you want to avoid soy products
especially soy protein isolates which is
in a lot of diet foods and
like the fake meat and things like that
and then you want to avoid things that
increase estrogen so you want to do
organic because
pesticides insecticides act like
estrogen in the body they're called
estrogen mimickers or endocrine
disruptors there are certain supplements
that can also help you
as well the most important one is zinc
about 100 milligrams per day
this will actually work very well
another good one that i recommend is the
korean red
ginseng this not only improves
testosterone but it's going to improve
your energy
it's going to give you a sense of
calmness it'll give you stamina
it'll give you vitality it's a really
really good herb it's been used for a
very
long long time with great success
l-arginine will increase something
called nitric
oxide which can increase testosterone
it's a
good supplement but remember any time
you're doing supplements
they may not work if your diet isn't
corrected
and if you don't know what to eat i put
a link down below
and then we have something called d
aspartic acid another really good
compound to help increase testosterone
last few points if you have a fatty
liver
and you're looking down you have a gut
you have a fatty liver
that's going to inhibit your ability to
make testosterone
so you want to work on removing the fat
from your liver
by doing a moderate protein low-carb
ketogenic diet also if your iron is too
high
that can suppress your testosterone and
it can destroy your liver so
i always recommend if you're male not to
take iron supplements
and even post-menopausal women who are
no longer menstruating
should be careful too because iron in
excess
is very harmful to your liver and
hormones
and it's very difficult for your body to
get rid of iron
so you want to be careful not to get it
in supplements
which you might even not be aware of
when you read the label it's like wow
i've been taking all this iron
no i wouldn't recommend that and statins
i already talked about that point all
right there you go
seven ways to boost your testosterone
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below check it out and get
signed up today